welcome everyone
to the class what we are going to talk
today about
is um some advanced topics and in
particular we are going first to talk
about
limitations of graph neural networks
and then we are also going about how do
we improve their expressive power
and how do we then
study how robust are graph neural
networks
against adversarial attacks
so the idea for today's lectures is
lecture is the following
um what would the perfect gnn model do
right if you want to say about what are
some limitations of graph neural
networks and especially when we
looked at their expressive power in
terms of the
um in terms of the um
wl uh kernel right if we go through a
thought experiment then we could say
what would a perfect graph neural
network do
and a k layer graph neural network
embeds a node
based on the k-hop neighborhood
structure around that node right and
this picture tries to illustrate that
that is that basically if i want to
embed
this particular note here i can take the
graph structure around this node and
then through message passing i want to
compute the embedding of that node
and a perfect gnn would be such that it
would build an injective function
between the
neighborhood structure around the target
node um
and the embedding that it produces so
essentially
what we'd like to do is with a perfect
gnn would take every different
node neighborhood structure and embed it
into a different position
uh in the embedding space um there are
two important
uh observations uh building on this
intuition first is that
a perfect gnn will do the following
right if two nodes have the same
neighborhood structure around the around
them
then they will have the same embedding
again here we are assuming there is no
discriminative
feature information given to us so v1
and v2 in this
in this graph with let's say two
connected components
will be embedded into the exactly the
same point
because the neighborhood structure
around them is identical and of course
right
if we have two nodes that have different
neighborhood structures
then um we'd like them to be embedded
into different points in the space
because
the net the the neighborhood structures
of these two nodes are different
one is in a triangle the other one is in
a square so they should be embedded into
different points so that's kind of
what we'd like to do that's what we'd
like our perfect
gnn to do however these
observations one and two may not be
always
true for example the the observation one
um can have kind of the following issues
even though two nodes may have the same
neighborhood structure around them
we may wanna assign um different
embeddings to them
um and this is because you know nodes
may appear in different positions
or in different locations in the graph
um and we uh we are going to call uh
this notion of a position in the graph
and these tasks that require
us understanding the position we'll call
those position aware tasks and i'm going
to define this more
uh precisely throughout uh the lecture
right so basically
even a perfect gnn that has that um
injective function between the
neighborhood structure and the embedding
will fail at these tasks for example
here if i have a
simple grid graph and i have nodes v1
and v2
and i'd like them to be embedded into
different points in space because they
are kind of at the opposite
ends of the of the underlying graph
actually a graph neural network is going
to embed them
into the same position because the
neighborhood structure around them
is identical they are both in the corner
of the grid
so this is kind of one issue that graph
neural networks as we have defined them
so far
are not able to do the second important
uh implication of the observation too is
that
um gnns that we have introduced so far
are kind of not perfect right their
expressive power um is not is not enough
right and in particular in lecture nine
we discussed
that the expressive power of a graph
neural network this message passing
graph neural network with
indiscriminative features uh its
expressive power is upper binder bounded
by the weiss filer layman
graphisomorphism test so for example
if i have nodes v1 on a cycle of length
3 and
node v2 on cycle of length 4 if i look
at the structure of their computation
graphs
the structure of the two computation
graphs will be the same
so without any discriminative node
features or if
assuming all node features are the same
graph neural network is not
going to be able to distinguish or it
won't be able to assign different
embeddings
to nodes one and uh two so basically
nodes v1 and v2 will always be
embedded into the same space uh under
the assumption that there is no useful
node features
um because their computation graphs are
identical even though
one resides in a triangle and the other
one resides in a square
so the plan for the lecture today is
that we want to resolve
both of these issues by building or
designing more expressive graph neural
networks
and the way we are going to fix these
issues is the following
to fix issue um one we are going to
create node embeddings based on their
positions in the graph
and the idea will be that we want to
create reference points in the graph
and then quantify the position of a node
against
those reference points and the class of
models
that allow us to do this are called
position aware graph neural networks
and then to fix the issue number number
two
um we we we are going to build a message
passing gnns
that are more expressive than the wl uh
test
um and the message an example of such a
message method is called
identity aware graph neural network so
this is what is going to be the
uh plan for the for the first part of
the lecture
and then in the last part i'm going to
talk about adversarial attacks
so uh here is our approach and this is
how we want to think about it
so um we will use the following thinking
um
given two different inputs for example
nodes
uh graphs uh edges um
let's assume they are labeled
differently and we are going to say that
you know kind of the model fails
um if it if it is always going to assign
the same embedding to these different
inputs or these different objects and a
successful model
is going to assign different embeddings
to these
different types of objects um so if we
focus let's say on node level embeddings
then you know embeddings in a gnn are
determined
uh by the underlying computation graph
right and in my case
imagine again i have a graph with two
connected components i have two vertices
v1 and v2 imagine v1 and v2 are labeled
with different labels v1 is labeled with
a
v2 is labeled with b the goal will be to
build a graph neural network that is
going to assign
different embeddings to node v1 then
to the node v2 again under the
assumption
that node features are the same or
non-discriminative between
v1 and v2 and perhaps what is you may
seem
you may say striking or interesting is
that the models we have
developed so far uh actually failed to
distinguish v1 and v2 like
even though we have built so much super
cool machinery that works amazingly well
in practice
and empirically we still cannot
distinguish v1 and v2 in this kind of
corner case
example so what we are going to do is to
understand how can we resolve this how
can we build a network
that a graph neural network that will be
able to distinguish
uh basically v1 and v2 so meaning assign
them different embeddings
so that then we can assign v1 one label
and we can assign v2 the other label
because we cannot assign them different
label
if they both map into the same point
so a naive solution to this that kind of
doesn't work
would be uh to use one holding what one
hot encoding so
we would like to say okay we don't have
any features but let us let's assign
each node
a different id and then we can always
differentiate different
nodes uh in in a graph or different
edges or even different graphs so
if i have you know two two graphs here
uh as we had before
i could simply assign a one hot encoding
to every node
um and now of course because nodes now
have uh
features it will be the computational
graphs will be distinguishable
because you know v1 will have two
children
one with zero one zero zero and the
other one with you know zero zero one
and v two is going to have um different
um
types of um uh neighbors because their
their um one hot encodings uh will be
different and even though if the two
if they will be the same at the first
level they won't be the same at the
second level so
basically computational graphs would be
different so our gnn
will be able to uh distinguish them um
what are the issues with this the there
are two very important issues
first is that this approach is not
scalable meaning we need an
order n feature dimensions where n is
the number of nodes to be able to encode
right basically we need a
separate feature for every individual
node and if you know we have
10 000 or 100 000 or a million node
network
then every node has now a million
features basically a one hot encoding
of its id uh and then the second problem
is that
this is in this is not inductive meaning
it won't generalize to
new nodes or new graphs because this one
hot encodings are kind of arbitrary note
ordering is arbitrary
so the net the network you basically
learn
according to that node ordering and then
if we um
try to transfer this to a new graph or
if a new node appears in the network
this won't this won't work right if a
new node appears we'll have to expand
extend the feature dimensionality
because we want to encode use one hot
encoding for that node as well and we'd
have to retrain
or if we want to transfer to a new graph
we have no guarantees because
the one hot encoding and node ids are
kind of arbitrary
so it won't it won't generalize so
this is why you know this is a bad bad
idea but
this idea kind of to enrich the nodes so
that we can
differentiate different computational
graphs is a good idea just one hot
encoding
doesn't work in this case